TODAY YOU ARE A TRUE GENTLEMAN,
HOCKEY LEGEND AND INSPIRATION
TO ALL.
SHORT SIDE IT IS 1-0 THANKS TO
.
REELING AND DEALING.
HE IS ON TRACK FOR OVER 20
GOALS THAT HE FIRES THE AND
HE SCORES!
CO BUT IT
STARTED A THE BLUE LINE.
THEY BROKE OUT.
THEY BURNED THE CAPSGTON.
WINNIPEG'S P.K.
HAS STRUGGLED DMITRI, THIS WAY,
EHLERS.
THE PERFECT
PINPOINT PASS FROM GARNETT
HATHAWAY, ELOGY VATTEDDED
AND WITHIT IS >> Joe: ORLOV FRO!
IT CHANGED DIRECTION AIT WENT FT
HELLEBUYCK.
HE WAS DEFINITELY SCREENEDPLAYI
GAME.
THE TWO-TIMEBACKSTROM DOWD, WHO.
AND AS OVECHKIN IT IS POGANSKI
TO
THE DEFENDER AND HE SCORES!
REAL NICE PLAY COMING BACK.
NATE SCHMIDT TRYINTHE VANECEK R
BALLGAME.
HERE IS THE ROTATION.
GOOD LONG-RANGE
SHOT BY FEHERVARY.
THE SECOND MOST N'T
THINK, WILL HAVE THE SERVICE OF
EHLERS WHO IN THREE-ON-THREE IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
AND HE LOOKS TO WRAP IT OFF